um yeah probably yeah yeah that'd be
okay
so um
we
got 150 when i left
senate finance it seemed like the this
bill was all set and
good to go and then it somehow
picked up a
friend along the way
probably late night probably after i
turned turned off
i was tuning into the senate a little
bit just
what time did you shut it off
what was it it was it was late it was
late i think we were there until
midnight yeah it was at least midnight
or afternoon no yeah
happy with what we've done i take it no
we we don't
so
like this on here what part are you not
happy with john uh let's uh
i had an amendment drama but it's so
simple it's probably silly uh it starts
at
section 86
of the bill yeah
so turned all the way back to the back
so obviously the amendment that i agreed
to in finance so i had told him that i'm
okay with putting the pushing the
effective date out right
okay
and just so you know
why i would
agree to such a crazy idea
is that um we were we would be one of
the first states to pass this ucc
legislation
and the uh ucf the uniform commercial
college
whatever they what they call themselves
they uniform commercial
no that's the code what's what's the
it's the use
council what's it called
ulc right so ulc which is the
uniform law commission
so they were say they put like the idea
that we would everybody would uh
have the law come into effect at the
same time
um but that the one thing that they are
happy about that
the fact that we're taking this up now
and passing it now
is that it really it's puts us on on
record notification to the whole country
that new hampshire is open to for
business for but with these
um guardrails
that the ucc creates
and and these are real guardrails and
that you know so that that um which you
know you you obviously know what a ucc
form is you know how important ucc is
so so
yes um
having even though it seems a little
bizarre having an effective date out but
that really is the more important thing
is is that that means
anybody who owns any crypto now in
new hampshire
knows that that they need to make sure
they conform
with the statute by the time it becomes
effective
so it's giving everybody pre-advanced
worrying here's here's the tattoo and
really is you know it's a win-win by
doing it this way good so you're happy
with that
so we're very happy with our of that
amendment yes i agree with that amount
and that is amendment 1939s
senate finance correct okay so we're
happy with that amendment it was just
the the amendment that started on
section 86
the steel the steel steel so that one
page
amendment two-page amendment
you're not happy with the rest of the
hundred and something pages you're happy
with right so so
if you want to visualize
that's that's short huh yeah so you pass
that one yeah they know what it says
yeah i'm pretty sure we do
so
both of these passed the senate
this was a separate bill the steel bill
was a separate bill and it passed the
house
my understanding is you guys killed it
no no no no no no
no no well you passed it in the house
correct
and
and do you know where the bill is now
if i can because i have a copy of the
docket of the bill right yeah it passed
the uh senate on march 31 2022 ought to
pass right voice vote
come down to the house
um the majority was
on 4 28 22 vote ought to pass on the
committee
on the floor on 504 222
um it was ought to pass with amendment
from the house from the house and then
what did the senate do what does the
last line say that yep we moved to
non-concur with the house amendment
because of what you attached to it right
but so
your motion of non-concur and you've
been doing this probably as long as i
have none concurred with that killed the
bill right
so so you killed it we killed it
because we did not accept what the house
had done to the bill
because the house attached another bill
to that bill and we said we're not
accepting that and then we took the bill
that we passed and attached it to this
bill
which everyone agreed to which everyone
has agreed to well like you said is that
the house you know in terms of what we
did is we sent you the bill and you
that is the bill but you've gone through
something that we
killed but
that the house commerce committee which
was the proponent of 1503 right
never saw
that steel issue at all we never had
anything to do with that bill and and
frankly it's offensive to be on 1503
well
and representative i will tell you that
there was a lot of offensive things
going on
between the house and the senate
especially the way that the bills the
senate bills were handled by the house
so
you know it as i said this is the silly
season people are attaching things left
and right
and so if that's the way the game's
going to be played then that's the way
the game's going to be played this was a
bill that passed the senate it passed
the senate committee five to nothing it
passed the floor on a voice vote came
over to the house
it passed the committee the house
committee until it got to the house
floor
and then someone from senate judiciary
attached a bill that we killed i know
excuse me edna that we killed attached
it to that bill and we said we're not
doing that absolutely not we wanted to
save this bill this bill was important
to the senate and we attached it to this
bill
so that's where we are today
that's it that's it so but like i say
i'm you know that
this
ucc bill
um obviously it's going to become a law
eventually
all right
and
you and i have both been around long
enough to know if it doesn't happen this
year then it'll happen next year it'll
happen and and it's a shame that that
would happen i agree i agree that the
game was even begun yeah but the first
shot didn't come from us well so i i'm
just saying if we're going to start
pointing fingers at each other right
it's important to realize that the
senate did not fire the first shot
it didn't come from us
the bill was attached
during a senate's during a house session
should never have happened why it
happened i can't speak to that that's
house business
but this bill was important to the
senate
and we wanted wanted to keep it alive
and that's exactly what we did
so
so what do you what do you want to do
you want us to walk away
um
well
you know i've been doing this for how
many years 36 years you know if you
really want to wait till next year
because you want to fall on your sword
over this issue all i'm just saying is
think about what you know here we are in
the state of new hampshire
you know i know i've put in the trust
laws i've done everything possible to
make us cutting edge
when it comes to financial services
and here we have this off the golden
opportunity
and to to put in a
um
in my opinion of the steel bill is you
know that this is a
taxpayer subsidy for for an old industry
and it's just not appropriate because it
opens up a can of worms because what
about lumber i mean there's the
canadians do a lot more than just steel
i mean there's a lot of things that they
do are we gonna if we're just gonna end
up having to subsidize every one of
these industries that the canadians and
i don't even ensure how the canadians
are you know i guess maybe because they
provide health insurance or something
i'm not sure where the advantages are
but all i know is if you start with this
steel bill next is going to be lumber
representative we will take them as we
get them as you know with any bill and
if someone wants to put in a bill
concerning lumber this legislature or
the next legislature will consider it we
had this bill concerning steel we
considered it we have steel
companies that manufacture steel here in
the state of new hampshire that provide
good paying jobs for people of the state
of new hampshire so we are protecting
those businesses and those people that
are working
we don't want to see people skilled
labor by the way
lose their jobs and leave this state to
have to go someplace else
so
um that is part of our position it's
very important to us it's important that
we protect those jobs and we protect
those industries even if it is an old
industry we need those people and we
need that industry
but once you do it then then when the
lumber comes in next year
the lord knows who else we can once you
pass this this you can open the can of
worms
well
then it'll be a can of worms
representative and we'll deal with it so
chris
if if i can make a comment i'm i'm all
for the steel bill i i think it makes a
lot of sense uh i think it uh
helps our constituents um if lumber
comes up next year we
again i think
you make a very good point we would have
to face that when it comes but right now
we got this on the table it it doesn't
look like it fits but i can think of the
uh
the budget bill that we passed uh last
year that
many things didn't fit and yet they were
put in there anyway so i i'm all for it
with the with the steel thank you
the
senate bill 2 is the only legislation
only bill is allowed to have all those
non-german amendments added to it
so
but i mean uh you know i don't know how
you feel if you want to we'll pick this
up again next week but at this point
um you know we we
we really need to have that out of this
bill i mean that that is just an
inappropriate amendment
a it's a slap in the face of what the
what the bill is trying to do
um and i think the best thing you know
for us to do is uh and i would urge you
to do with the other bills just clean
them up and get get the things that you
you feel is the are the right things and
have them in the bill and that's the way
they should be passed
well um i'm not the chair of this
committee senator francis john we'll
come back next week but i really would
like you to reconsider your position
when we do i really think this is an
important underlying bill and the bill
we've added
does not destroy it
i really would like you to think that
through
i don't know if we have the support on
our side to pass this without
so you put us in a real difficult time
sorry to do that to you because you know
i know you've had a lot of great working
years together
we'll miss you when you're not chairman
next year but but uh well you might get
kevin no
kevin back yeah
so but anyway i i just give it some
thought yeah and set up another meeting
for next week
and talk to your caucus see where they
are
this bill should this underlying bill
so let's do it
okay well obviously to me it's it's
really offensive
it really is offended it's a slap in the
face of of this you know here we are of
the of what we're trying to do um
the fight
look at it this way the steel bill came
to commerce yeah it wouldn't have passed
because it would have been a precedent
that we didn't want to we wouldn't want
to go down yeah okay
so the fact that it did pass i you know
obviously i i hear you you never voted
for something you didn't like ever in
your 47 years here
give a take
um
i i have to say is that i i have to i
have to figure out rationale how how i
can get my answers
and
yeah you have to turn your mic on chris
um just
one additional comment um
a lot of democrats are very suspicious
of 1503
i think adding the steel bill to it
would uh
almost guarantee that the democrats
would support the whole package other
than that
you take the seal bill out i don't think
you're going to get the democratic
fair enough
i understand why you're offended and i
can honestly say i'm probably just as
more as offended as you are
because a bill dealing with cosmetology
was attached to the steel bill
now please tell me how that works
it should never have happened but that's
house business and that's how you chose
to handle your bills
we don't have anything to say about it
so while you're
offended i'm equally as offended but i'm
trying to find a solution here
so we can get a bill that has passed the
senate
as well as the house committee
passed into law
so
like that i mean no i hear you but but
sharon
why didn't you go to comedian conference
why did you kill it
not playing games this is just
what are you going to do so you're
saying if i should have just killed this
bill
not to play games so the fact that you
added the steel one to it would have
been way way way too many committees a
conference way way way too many
conference committees conferences take a
look at all the bills that we
non-concurred with
because bills were attached that made no
sense whatsoever
so what we did was we focused on the
bills that were important to the senate
well that's great but
the question i'm sure because this bill
is important to the house this bill is
okay so at any rate i i guess we'll be
meeting again on committee conferences
on bills that that died in commerce
and suddenly appeared on
totally non-germane health and human
services committee so
you know this is
so you can say that you know we started
it but you obviously ran with it because
you were here
until midnight and we've decided to go
home by then so that we weren't going to
play this tit for tad for you know all
night long so
um you know
i
i'm not i don't play these games this is
you know commerce is we've never had
these kind of issues before this is this
is new to me to have that all my years
to have bills that that uh that
that congress never had get attached to
an important issue but let alone the
fact that we will be meeting again on
monday on another bill you know that
commerce bill that we killed that now is
just found in a new home
so i mean i just i agree with you this
this is very frustrating and this is
so we just have to find some way we can
do the right thing
and do the right thing for new hampshire
that's it
you